مياس مجددا في عرض مبهر ديما قندلفت مع
سلطان العاشقين حياه الفهد تشغل بال
محبيها وحسن الرداد يشارك جمهوره بفيلمه
الجديد الابرز في
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسبوع بعد فوزها بلقب الموسم الفائت ابهلت
فرقه مياس اللبنانيه مجددا جمهور برنامج
المواهب الشهير امريكا كالنت بتقديم عرضها
المصور الاول حره في افتتاح الحلقه
الاخيره من هذا الموسم وجسدت من خلال احدى
اللوحات التي قدمتها تمثال الشهداء بلبنان
في رساله تحمل ابعادا وطنيه وسط دهشه
الجمهور ولجنه تحكيم البرنامج وحققت
الفيديوهات المتداوله من العرض تفاعلا
كبيرا على منصات التواصل في لبنان والعالم
[موسيقى]
العربي
جابكو فشد انتبهكو اه ومن الرقص الى
الاصدارات الموسيقيه واغنيه جديده اصدرها
سلطان الطرب جورج والسوف الاسبوع الماضي
بعنوان نجمه عالي من كلمات ملاك عادل
والحان محمد يحيى واعربت الفنانه السوريه
ديما قندلفت عن سعادتها بمشاركه من وصفته
سلطان العاشقين كليب الاغنيه الذي اخرجه
طوني قهوجي وتجاوز عدد مشاهداته المليون
مشاهده في ثلاثه ايام ويتواصل التفاعل على
نطاق واسع مع اصدارات اصاله الغنائيه
الجديده من البوم لحقت نفسي الذي اطلقت
الجزء الاول منه في الاول من اكتوبر
الجاري لو علي فانا عايزه مر عيني تتقفل
تمل والى الدراما التلفزيونيه والاعتذار
المفاجئ من الفنانه الكويتيه حياه الفهد
عن عدم استكمال مسلسل يجمعها بمواطنتها
الفنانه سعاد عبد الله كان من المقرر ان
يعرض في موسم دراما رمضان 2024 المقبل
الفنانه حياه الفهد اعلنت الاعتذار عبر
حسابها الرسمي على انستغرام وبررت بظروف
خاصه وصحيه تمر بها في الوقت الراهن ما
اثار قلق محبي الفنانه الكويتيه الكبيره
خليجيا ايضا تتواصل التهاني من زملاء
ومحبي الفنان احمد العونان الذي تعود
اصوله للبدون في الكويت بمنحه الجنسيه
الاماراتيه مؤخرا ونقلت صحف كويتيه عن
العونان قوله ان الجنسيه الاماراتيه مدعاه
فخر واعتزاز وشرف بالنسبه له ضيفا الكويت
والامارات بيت واحد وخليجنا واحد وانا
خرجت من دار الى
دار سينمائيا شارك الفنان المصري حسن
الرداد جمهوره تصوير مشهد من فيلمه المقبل
لوندو بطريقه مبتكره حيث دعاهم ال
الانضمام الى بث مباشر على تيك توك يظهر
فيه بشخصيته في الفيلم ومن تفاعل مع هذا
البث كان له فرصه الظهور بالفيلم المقرر
اطلاق عرضه في موسم راس السنه
المقبل ضرب ض ض
ض ونختتم الابرز بالتفاعل الواسع في
العالم العربي مع خبر رحيل المطربه
اللبنانيه نجاح سلام المحزن عن عمر 992
عاما ابنتها سمر نعتها بالقول انتهى
المشوار يا عروبه في عباره مقتبسه من
اغنيه سوريا يا حبيبتي التي شاركت بها قبل
50 عاما بمناسبه حرب اكتوبر لم ينته
الموار يا
عروب حت
الفنانه الراحله الحائزه على الجنسيه
المصريه ايضا انشدت المصريين واحده من
اجمل اغانيهم الوطنيه يا اغلى اسم في
الوجود يا اغلى اسم في
الوجود يا يا اسم مخلق الخلود
يا